Looking at landscape splines next.
You can see that in this image here,
you can see the splines being used to map out a road
and some barriers here.
And so landscape splines can do a number
of really interesting things in your landscape.
We can place splines down by holding down the Control key
and clicking on the landscape,
and then we can move and rotate and modify
the tangent handles of the landscape splines.
In a similar way, you might have used the spline tool
in a number of other ways inside of Unreal.
It's the same controls there to move the tangent handles.
And we can just click the landscape spline icon,
which you can see here in the viewport
to allow you to do this.
So you can deform the landscape using splines as a guide,
and it's great for making paths or roads.
And to do that, you just go to the tool settings,
click on the deform landscape to splines option,
and then we can do this through the all splines
or just the current one selected.
So you can see an example here of using the spline
in the details panel under landscape spline.
You wanna press the segments buttons
to select all the landscape splines.
And if done correctly, you should now see the option
in the details panel called the landscape spline mesh.
So if you select the landscape spline mesh
and press the plus icon to add a new static mesh
to the array, we can add a road for example,
like in this image.
So for the mesh, we can import the SM underscore street
static mesh, which I'll do here in a second in the editor
to show you exactly what's going on.
And then we just want to uncheck center horizontally
and change the forward axis to Y
because of the orientation of the road mesh.
Just make sure you uncheck cash shadow
on your road setting mesh.
More for an aesthetic reason,
doesn't necessarily need to be done,
but it just looks a little bit cleaner
when we add that road spline.
So let's jump into the editor here and do that.
So when we're back in our editor here,
we can go to the manage tool at the top,
select splines, we're still in our landscape mode as well.
And then as mentioned, you hold down control and left click.
And so that will add a key onto the landscape.
So you can see that we've got landscape spline selected
and you can just hold down alt and drag
to create a second spline path here.
So I'm just going to grab my road mesh.
I'm just going to right click on my content,
create a folder called meshes.
And from the other screen, I'm just going to drag in my FBX,
which is the SM street FBX that we were talking about before.
So we've got the street and let's just save all there
and just make sure everything's saved correctly.
So now in the detail setting of the landscape,
we then want to find this details panel
and we want to go to the segments section of the landscape.
So we can select the segments
and then we want to go to the landscape spline mesh.
And press the plus icon.
And then you'll see this index here
and it's looking for a mesh.
So we just want SM street mesh found here.
And then we want to uncheck center horizontally.
As you can see, it's come in on the different axis.
So let's just uncheck center horizontally
and change the forward axis to Y.
There we go.
And so we can untick our shadow again for aesthetic reasons,
completely optional and up to you.
But you can start to see how we might be able
to edit this landscape based on the different settings
that we have available to us using the spline tools.
So if I just hit space bar,
you'll see I've got my gizmo here.
And essentially again,
as beautiful as we made this landscape look,
you can make your roads look beautiful.
You can hold down alt to add a new point.
Again, like we said, we have the same widgets
and gizmos available to us when making landscapes.
So we can move these around.
Again, you can like lift these up, et cetera, et cetera.
You can kind of get the idea,
but hopefully that gives you a good starting point
for using splines on your landscape.
Again, some of the settings that you'll need
are to do with the segments of the mesh that you're using.
If you're importing a mesh that doesn't look quite correct,
just check whether the center horizontally needs
and check in and also which the forward axis is.
So if Y is the forward axis for your mesh,
just make sure you set that.
And then we untick shadow in this instance
just to make it look a little bit more visually pleasing.